[Music]
hey guys in this video we're going to
talk about a theory image Danny will get
betrayed for love by miss sandy who is
in this theory no one there's even a
deleted scene between the enemies saying
that there could be hinting to such a
twist that might happen in the final
season but before we get there let's
start from the beginning who is Miss and
a Miss ed is Danny's advisor confident
and translator miss I miss ad being
devoted to Danny there are a few things
about her that are a little bit
suspicious let's start with the fact
that me send a young woman on the show
and a little 10 years old girl in the
books is speaking all those different
languages which is a little bit strange
to say at least it's not about how
someone could learn 19 different
languages but it's strange how could
someone Yungas incentives learn all
those languages in such a short period
of time have ever been a compared it to
a girl who turned out to be 36 years old
a girl that re-emitting Bravo's this
makes sense to me it could be the
missing is a much older person which
will explain how she learned all those
languages said such an engage especial
in the Box damaged miss and is only 10
years old so basically by this theorem
is saying is no one wearing a face of
someone who is very young at the moment
of their death very observant fan as I
am would notice how me sandy once
mentioned that while she was swimming
she heard someone scratching at the wall
salt crumbling bricks as a confirmation
that Miss sandy has superpowers or we
could say a faceless man assessing
skills in the books there's also
mentioned that Miss and I overheard a
sexual encounter between Danny and
Darian Harris she heard the sound of
lawmaking which led her to us day and in
the morning about her health since she
misunderstood the meaning of the sounds
to me sandy hearing yes the poor is
scratching desperately from half a mile
away be a hint at her supernatural
abilities invokes miss Ella seems to
hear more than most people and seems to
be trying to tell them in so many words
how desperate the slaves are without
giving she's a spy another skill miss
Standish shares to the faceless man is
her ability to sneak up on anyone she
wants no matter how skilled an
experienced person she sneaks up on is
in the books miss and even manages to
sneak up on sir Barristan the protector
of Danny and famous member the
Kingsguard who is always on the alert
just earlier in his point of view sir
bars to sell me things about Kings guard
needing to always be on alert he says
but the battle was never truly done for
a knight of the Kingsguard
threats came from everywhere in nowhere
at any time of day or night
no trumpets announce the foe vessel
sermons friends brother son Steven wise
any of them might have knives concealed
beneath their cloaks and murder hidden
in their hearts for every hour fighting
a Kingsguard nights spent 10,000 are
watching waiting standing silent in the
shadows and then just a bit later after
that sir Burton gets snuck up on by in
Sandy hears that part from the books she
might be flying home he told himself
aloud no murmur the saw was behind him
she would not do that sir she would not
go home without us sir bars and turned
me sandy child how long have you been
standing there
it's definitely odd for a child to
manage to sneak up to arguably one of
the best fighters the most accomplished
member of the Kingsguard Westeros has
ever had missin this life story is also
suspicious miss sandy said that she and
her brothers were born it not statement
which many doubt some even claim that
there's a hidden clue proving a myth
sandy is not from there or at least the
one who wears face of miss sandy is not
from not in season seven devil says me
sandy where she's from since he cannot
place the accent this was the first red
flag as many wonder how Davos is unable
to place racks and because he's
literally sailed everywhere she didn't
reveal that she's from the island of
naath
the devil says that he heard it's
beautiful there yet he hasn't visited
the island himself Davos says that the
island is apparently full of palm trees
and butterflies its end it doesn't
elaborate and just walks away which
implies that she could be lying about
her true origins many theorize that she
doesn't say yes or no because she's
never been there herself and as no idea
whether Davos is claimed search or not
however this is not true early on Inga
materials miss sandy and grave warm her
conversation and miss sandy does know
how not looks like she said I'm from an
island called naath and continued with I
remember when they rowed us away from
shore how wide the beaches were how told
the trees and I remember my village
burning smoke rising into the sky so
theory that miss sandy doesn't even know
how her homeland looks like is not true
however it doesn't mean that the theory
in which miss sandy is not really sandy
but rather a faceless man wearing face
to me sandy is not true remember that
faceless man have to study the one which
they plan to kill in order to learn
every detail from that one's life
and in order to portray the person
perfectly whilst wearing their face in
the future to truly become that person
so of course that did the faceless man
is ring face on the same day of course
that he or she would know where me
saying they was from and how her
homeland looks like let's focus on the
biggest clue which might confirm them is
saying there really is no one the
greatest gloomy saintly being no one is
amiss and is referring to herself as
this one something she struggles sit in
both books and show despite her episode
ownage of linguistics I know that most
of you think that Mustaine is referring
to herself as this one meaning her slave
title as a result of them not him names
let me say in the his/her name and
additionally Messiah is not a slave
anymore which could only mean the Miss
Saint is someone else the Messiah is no
one oh so I'm aware that you might say
that faceless may refer to themselves as
a man or a woman not this one but you
might be wrong faceless men are not
actually supposed to talk like that
Jackie refers to himself as a man not as
a result of him being one of the
faceless men which his but as a result
of the faceless man impersonating
jocking let me explain
a face that this faceless man is using
once belonged to Jackie agar who was
from laureth and there we come to her
answer on why this faceless man is
referring to himself as a man it's
because Jackie was a person who lived in
Lloret before he was killed
and before his face ended up in the Hall
of faces and in that city everyone talks
that way it's a place where everyone is
referring to himself as a man or a girl
and that's the only reason why this
faceless man that fears the face of
Jackie gar is referring to himself as a
man because remember the faceless men
are guild of assassins they are trained
to relinquish their former identities
and become no.1 or in this case the
Loretto criminal by the name of Jackie
and therefore adopt all of his
characteristics in order to impersonate
him as best as they can the faceless men
actually have to refer to themselves as
a current character have to refer to
themselves as this one which miss st. is
doing this theory ever comes true it's
explained how miss Andy learned all
those languages at such a young age but
it would also explain her being
extremely telogen Tana litical for age
especially for age in the books in the
Boxter Bartholomew's wanna miss and his
ideas in negotiation with the enemy
which was offering each man's waiting
gold for the release of the hostages sir
burst and finally same strategy
reminiscent of both
Baelish Hills plans are including bribes
and various plans are including
fostering division in the enemy ranks
just take a look at this sir bars and
some equality when comparing missandei
to the ruling council Marine he said the
11 years of age yes and is as clever as
half of the men at his table and wiser
than all of them all of this evidence
made me believe that the faceless man is
impersonating him very missed a nice
face well behind that face there's
someone much older explaining how miss
sandy knows all these languages but it's
also so clever at such a young age when
in fact the person beneath that face is
much older in me sandy really is one of
assassins that serves the many-faced God
it comes along with even more questions
than need to be answered is insanely
actually helping Danny or she'll betray
her when the time is right let's begin
with the fact that the faceless men
founders were once slaves who worked in
mines there's a story about the first
faceless man a story in which one man
heard the prayers of either slaves to
their various gods and came to conclude
that they all prayed to the same God
with a hundred different faces the
many-faced God this led the first
faceless men to give the gift of death
for the most desperate slave later they
brought that same gift to the Masters as
well now when you are introduced for the
fact that the faceless men are against
slavery could it be that the many-faced
God sent one of us says since with the
face of miss sandy at slavers Bay to
kill the good masters of the city of
este / and to end slavery but before she
could Danny arrived and did it herself
well it's certainly possible but the
most important question do the faceless
men support Danny's campaign against
slavery at first glance the answer is
obvious since then released and set free
every slave she came across but the
faceless men might consider Danny a nerd
three dragons along with while the
Trekkie horde has another symbol of
oppression but the real clue to miss and
his treachery lies in a deleted scene
where Danny warns me sandy never to be
traitor that interesting deleted scene
you can fight on Game of Thrones
official YouTube channel and it should
have been included in one of season 4
episodes but Co producers decided not to
release it the scene includes the name
sandy and what happens there is the same
that happened in the books and it might
be foreshadowing me Sandy's eventual
betrayal and it seemed is sandy joins
Danny in the terrace garden and then he
tells her never betray me on which means
and replies simply with never could a
deleted scene before sharing something
that is going to happen in the future
the scene could be foreshadowing what
come which could very well be me Cindy
between Dane it's a well-known fact that
writers like a bit of foreshadowing
ingame drums and this would be evidence
of the fact my thoughts are divided but
considering them is sandy has not done
anything that will cause Danny to say
that or maybe proper word would be to
Warner I'll just wait for the final
season to save that really was some kind
of a sharing some claim that miss sandy
the faceless men have already made moves
against Danny as many believe that
Daniel already got betrayed season 7 so
Danny attempts at seizing the Iron
Throne destroyed by bad luck or
sometimes for decision making yet cut
her losses to the Lannisters actually be
the result of a spy traitor within her
inner circle who's giving information to
Danny's enemies in order to weaken ur
many fans believe that somebody from
Danny's group gave information to
someone about the planned invasion of
castle rock and location of yds forces
and fence point out to me Santa being
the traitor and being a part of a
faceless man guild what do you guys
think about all of this miss Sandy's
character is definitely suspicious
better being dead smart and wise knowing
all these languages at such a young age
do you guys think the miss sandy
referring to herself as this one just
like the faceless men do is suspicious
let me know your opinion on all of this
in the comment section down below and as
always I hope you guys enjoyed this
video if you did please make sure to
subscribe to our Channel and I hope to
see you in the next one peace